a bit late that's okay all right we're
now
sure you're now live thank you tom right
well
i'd like to welcome everybody the
committee officers
and members of the public who'll be
watching this on
youtube hopefully to the plans committee
of torridge's plans committee of the 4th
of march
just a few things i want to go through
at the start of the meeting
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones or if people
keep themselves muted except mine please
leave them
muted unless you're asked to speak by by
me to speak
public speaking residents who want to
exercise this right
in the public speaking part of the
agenda
have been asked to register in advance
and also have had
the option of sending a statement to us
which will be read out by
our planning manager or they've been
sent a link
to temporarily join the meeting to speak
in person
we have four four people registered to
speak today
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or propose or second emotion
please press the raise the hand symbol
in the participants menu on your screen
these are shown on my screen in the
order that they are pressed
and i will deal with them in that order
giving the appropriate officer
or counselor the opportunity to answer
in between where necessary i will also
return to the counsellor
to check that they're happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings all votes
will be cast by a verbal recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your names read out
unmuting and muting your microphone is
necessary
and please remember that to ensure full
transparency
this democratic proce of the with the
democratic process
this meeting is being live streamed on
the council's youtube channel as i
said at the start i do ask you all to be
patient particularly with me
during this meeting and to understand
that processes
and advice may take a little longer than
usual
i'll now ask each committee member to
introduce themselves
and the officers present so sandra if
you set the ball rolling with the
committee members please
thank you chair council about him
yep good morning i'm richard bowden i
represent heartland ward
good morning i represent um great
torrington
thank you councillor christie good
morning my name is peter christie i
represent biddeford north cancer craigie
good morning um my name's ruth craigie
and i represent bit of an east
councillor leather
good morning everybody i'm chris leather
and i represent northam
canceler lock good morning my name is
rosalie lock and i represent
two rivers and three walls councilman
golf
good morning my name is der goff i
represent biddeford north
cancer watson yeah good morning pete
watson i represent broad heath
and councillor wiseman hello richard
wiseman and i represent the
shebia and langtry ward
thank you chair if the officers now
would like to
introduce themselves starting with the
planning manager please
uh good morning members members of
public my name's sean harrington and i'm
the planning manager at torres district
council
hello i'm stacey dorey and i'm the head
of legal and governance attorney
council
the officer is present because i think
we've got some officers present
planning morning members and members of
the public my name is peter stapley
graduate planning officer
good morning members good morning
members of the general public my name's
tracy blackmore i'm a principal planning
here at torres district council
good morning members and all members of
the public my name is helen
smith and i am a development management
team leader here at torres district
council
and i believe we've got highways officer
present
matt collins good morning all
matt collins devon county council
highways
thank you that's that's everybody that's
a principal
people present this morning okay uh
item one on the agenda is apologies for
absence well
we've got a full compliment on the
committee so thank you for that
item two on the agenda is to receive the
minutes from the meetings two meetings
we had
21st of january and um
a special meeting held on the 4th of
february and i'd like to move those
two sets of minutes from the chair
please if somebody'd like to second it
i'll second it thank you councillor
watson
sound removed my hand right thanks
councillor watson okay
sandra if you'd like to go to the vote
please almost two sets of minutes
yes chair cancel about him for
counselor brown for chancellor christie
oh
pence lecraegee or councillor leather
or chancellor lock or
hansel mcgoff
four uh councillor watson off
councillor wiseman oh
unanimous chair thank you sandra
item two on item three on the agenda is
declarations of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
considered
elected members of devon county council
and the town and parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue
of their membership of that council hold
a personal interest
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not bind the members concerned
who considered the application afresh
and i always
tell uh for the members of the public's
notice that it is only at this meeting
that we have all the facts
and some come very late on the agenda
sometimes but
parish and town councils don't have
necessarily all the facts when they look
at an application
okay item four on the agenda is to agree
uh between parts one and two well there
is no part two
and item five urgent matters
i have nothing urgent to bring to the
committee only that
after the formal meetings closed of that
members to stem because we have one or
two things
we need to discuss at the end of the
meeting
chair counselor christie's raised his
hand councillor christie
yeah thank you can i just ask um when
are we gonna reinstate putting up
planning notices
um by planning applications because uh
i've had a couple of counselors say to
me that
planning applications have gone in where
no planning notice has gone up and
obviously not everyone
sees it in the newspaper or goes online
so
uh how quickly are we going to do that
sean would you like to answer that
please have plenty uh
yes of course chair uh thank you
councillor christie
we're currently working on our lockdown
site
notice protocol and what that
essentially means is that we
place site notices that are statutory
required
certain applications by law have to have
a slight notice and they are still going
up
it's the non-essential site notices that
weren't going up during lockdown
and that's the same with lockdown one
lockdown two and the present situation
at the end of this lockdown in line with
the government's roadmap we will be
going back to our previous protocol of
site nursing uh planning applications in
their entirety uh so that is the 27th of
march i believe
thank you thank you sean following on
from that could you just mention
uh when we write we rewrite to any
neighbors of any application site um
yeah
of course chair um as part of the
lockdown protocol whilst we weren't
uh site noticing every application
because it was non-essential
we did extend the area which we
write neighbours normally we would only
write to neighbours that shared a common
residential boundary
with a site because that's essentially
what our i.t system will allow us to do
um but we did extend that to a wider
area so a wider group of community would
know about the application
and it was on our website and did go
into the paper as well
thank you sean thank you for that right
item
six on the agenda then is public
participation
um we've got four speakers this morning
to speak to the wooder road application
um and after the
the order of speakers is the planning
officer will give their
presentation of the application first of
all and then any town or parish council
who has a representative who wishes to
speak for or against the application
they have three minutes well we haven't
got a
parish or town council person to speak
this morning
then up to two members of the public who
wish to speak against the application
they get three minutes each allocated
and then up to two members of the public
who want to speak in support of an
application
they again are allocated three minutes
to speak
and then any torridge council member
from the ward in which the application
falls they can speak and there's no time
limit
on their contribution right
okay um item seven then is planet
planning applications
the information recommendations and
advice contained in the reports
are correct as at the date of
preparation which is more than 10 days
in advance of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or orally
at the committee meeting
so our first application is 7a
on pages 16 to 23
and planning officer peter staplet would
take you through this
this has come to us because the
applicant is a relative
of a staff member of the planning team
at torridge chair councillor christie's
raised his hand
answer christy can i just say i'm dual
hatted on this one
thank you pete thank you council
christie
okay thank you peter thank you thank you
chair
and as you rightly pointed out this
application seeks detailed planning
permission for the erection
of a two-story rear extension and
extensions to the existing porch and
garage
and this application has to be
determined by committee due to the
applicant being a member
a relative of a member of staff in the
planning department
next slide please
this is the location plan for the
application site which you can see is
outlined in the center of the image
as you can see the site is located
within the residential area and it's
within the settlement boundary of
biddeford
the site consists of a detached dwelling
with the principal elevation to the west
and private immunity space to the east
next slide
please
again this is an area image showing the
context of the site
and once again you can see the
neighboring properties immediately to
the north and south of the site
with access from the highway that runs
along the west boundary
the next slide please
here you can see it attached dwelling in
the context of the street
with the application dwelling in the
center of the image
you can see that the ground level varies
considerably either side of the
application
site next slide please
again this is a photograph for the front
elevation of the dwelling
just to guide members the application
seeks extensions the existing portion
garage which you can see
on the left and right there
next slide please
this is a photo of the rear elevation
whether a proposal includes the erection
of a two-story extension
the full width of the rear elevation to
provide additional living accommodation
next slide please
this slide shows the rear garden which
demonstrates the site benefits from
sufficient amenity space
and that the site can accommodate the
proposed rear extension
next slide please
there are the existing floor plans with
the main living accommodation on the
ground floor and on the first floor the
larger the three bedrooms
the front of the house and two single
bedrooms the rear
here are the proposed floor plans
clearly showing the rear extension
providing spacious limited accommodation
on the ground floor and two double
bedrooms at first floor
you can also see the extensions the
existing garage and porch
and a reconfiguration of the rear
terrace decking
next slide please
this slide shows the existing
elevational drawings of the house
and here are the proposed elevations
which shows the two-story rare extension
and extensions of the garage and porch
the rear extension will extend beyond
the rear elevation by approximately 4.5
meters
and will span the total width of the
dwelling the ridge and eaves height will
match the existing dwelling
and so were the materials
next slide please the material planning
considerations in this case are the
principal development
the impact on character appearance
residential amenity
access parking and highways and ecology
hopefully you've read my report which
sets out why i'm recommending this
application for approval
thank you for listening i'll be happy to
answer any questions you may have and
i'll pass back
over to you chair thank you peter
councillor locke yeah i've read the
report and just seen some interesting
photographs
um i see there's no objections on
overlooking
any of their neighbours mainly because
all the works are at the rear of the
property
um benevolent town council recommended
approval
um there's no objection to the
environmental protection officer
but to include the working hours um
during construction condition i see that
has been done
so i would recommend approval of the
application
thank you council mark councillor watson
i'll second that chair
thank you councillor watson anybody else
like to contribute to the discussion on
this if not
sandra would you take the vote it's been
proposed by councillor locke
seconded by councillor watson that this
is granted could you please take the
vote sandra
yeah thank you chair council about him
at four councillor brown four
chancellor christie oh hence the craigie
or penciller leather poor
chancellor lock or nestle mcgoff
four councillor watson or
councillor wiseman that's unanimous
chair
thank you sandra that we move on then
to application 7b
which is on pages 24 to 34.
shut up sorry sorry chair sorry
i'm talking to the dog if you want to
mute you
thank you watson right uh
yeah the application is on page 24
and this is sandy mirror road carrying
the boris and tracy blackmore planning
officer will take this
present this application thank you tracy
thank you chair
so um yes as we say it's page 24 of your
agenda so this application is seeking
full
planning permission for improvements to
an existing access road
including raising the level of the road
to northern boroughs
country park there are no updates um for
members from when my report was written
so the first slide just shows the
location plan of the site
so the site relates as i said to an
access road
located within northern burroughs
country park the section of road to be
improved is outlined
in red four members this is an aerial
photo of the site and again the access
road for the proposed improvements have
been identified in red
the proposed enclosed includes the
reconstruction of approximately 350
meters
of that existing internal access road
and just some photos for members this is
the view of the existing access road as
members can see the existing sort of
tarmac road
has a rough surface and sandy edges to
the west is bare mud
sand of sandimir lake and to the east
encompasses a strip of coastal grassland
um some more photos of the existing
access road as members can see
um currently the lowest part of the road
is is
inundated a number of times several
times a year
by tidal waters which effectively cuts
off the access to northern borough's
visitor center so
this is just a quick slide demonstrating
the existing section of the road again i
said to you it's 350 meters to be
improved so moving on swiftly to the
proposal so the proposal includes the
reconstruction
of 350 metres of the access road to
include
raising the level of the road by 1.2
metres
the reconstructed access road will have
a sloping permeable grass
crete area to the west and this will
effectively improve the surface water
runoff and reduce the overall area of
tarmac involved
so this is a bit more of construction
details this section
relates to the area of road nearer to
the t
junction at the western end of sandimir
road
and this is another construction drawing
um
showing the road which is nearer to the
northern borough center
which shows um the sort of grass creek
and the verge and a lot of the
improvements to be made to the
carriageway
my last slide is just a section drawing
um
again showing that the proposed
reconstructed road will um
include it having been raised to 1.2
metres
and including um the field to the
sub-based material
with a finished specification of the
grass creek system
so just quickly moving on to the main
planning considerations of the
application
so the principle of developments
currently the lowest part of the access
road
is inundated by tidal water several
times a year
effectively cutting off access to the
visitor centre
the proposed improvement to the access
road will enable year around
access to the venue to the new visitor
center and also to the new cafe
and toilet block which members will
remember got granted planning permission
at the end of last year um so you know
this is acceptable in accordance with
our policy
set out in my report so they're going on
to the next consideration visual impact
and landscape character
um there have been no objections from
the era of
aomb team it is considered that these
improvements to the access road would
not cause significant harm
and actually would have some gains in
terms of using a grass creek
and allowing more vegetation to grow on
the site
drainage and flood risk so in order to
reduce the frequency of the water
over topping the access road it is
proposed to raise the reconstructed road
above one in
200 year tidal level the pro surface
water drainage system
will be in accordance with suds um so
highway safety
the works are internal within the site
and aim to improve the
all-year vehicle access to the visitor
center and
the site for the new cafe and toilet
block ecology natural england have been
consulted on this application
as members will see from my report and
have no objections
the application has been supported by an
ecological appraisal which says there
would be no
impact on habitats and protected species
and there would be biodiversity gain
through the creation of additional grass
and habitat restatement
so therefore the recommendation chair
for this application is approval
thank you tracy thank you for that
well i only drove down to the borough
center this morning when i took the two
dogs
out over the golf course earlier on and
uh as tracy said that road
does flood a lot through the wintertime
and that issue was raised when the new
borough center was being
discussed so uh i'm going to recommend
from the chair approval of this because
i think it's part it goes hand in hand
with
the the new visitor center down and it'd
be a nonsense
not to do this road work i think i
cancelled a lot
yeah just one small point um on page
27 natural england talk about southwest
coastal
park and to ensure that walkers can
still use the path
additional signage should be put in
place is this
covered um by condition three on page 33
or should we add an addendum to that
condition sound about additional
signage yes so thank you chair so that
has all been included in the um
construction
ecology management plans that will it
has all been set out
and natural england have agreed that
they're happy with that
all right that's right in that case then
i will second yeah it has been slightly
updated to make sure that all those
recommendations by natural england um
including the grass creek
um not being plastic has all been
updated so that has all been reflected
in in that management plan
thank you thank you tracy
well i proposed it from the chair and
council lock seconded it
um nobody else wants to speak on this
well
so sandra could you go to the vote on
this please it's been
proposed by myself councillor lever
secondly by councillor locke
to grant this thank you chair council
about him
at four chancellor brown or
pencer christie oh that's the craigie
or spencer leather or
pencil lock or pencil mcgough
or cancer watson or
cancer wiseman oh that's unanimous chair
thank you sandra right we go on to
our third application application 7c
which is on pages 35 to 59
and this is the land at wooder road
apple door
and helen smith is the planning officer
who will present this application
thank you yeah sorry i'm sorry sorry to
intervene and i'm sorry helen
um the public speakers are now in there
were some technological problems
um bizarre in relation to this
application
um they didn't get the link so can we
do the public speaking i know it's
irregular but
but because of their internet connection
um
they've only just come in so that they
should have the opportunity to speak
they will stacey will have the
opportunity to speak after the
presentation
says just that we've gone past the
public participation point that that was
all that's why i was raising it
now well it was all i was hoping there
were the time we got to the application
that the public speakers were here
that's okay so just plug it out helen
will present that
and then the public speaking comes in
then
as per our protocol okay thank you thank
you chair
and yes this this application um
reference one zero eight seven one
twenty twenty
rem is a reserved matters application
um focusing on details of appearance
landscaping
layout and scale and it's pursuant to
the outline planning approval
one one forward slash one three four
three twenty eighteen o utm
the the application proposes 88
dwellings and associated infrastructure
and open space at wooder road members
will recall that
the outline application came before them
twice i think it was november 2019 and
then again in january 2020
and at that point the principle was
established but also access was for
consideration
and and the the detailed point of access
onto wooder road
was approved at that point there is
further consideration of just the
technical detail of an access to pitt
hill
as part of this application
so before before i run through the
presentation there are a number of
verbal updates that i need to give you
i have put them as bullet points on the
presentation i'll i will just work
through them one by one
firstly the first point um as
the committee report was published as
you're aware on the 19th of february
prior to this on the 16th of february
some revised plans were uploaded to our
our planning website these plans
correspond with the
the drawings that are listed in your
committee reports your agenda reports
the the changes that were made within
these drawings related primarily to the
removal of one dwelling
so the application originally proposed
89 dwellings
the application before you today is 88
dwellings
the reason for the removal of one plot
being plot 59
was to address concerns raised by devon
county council's fled
flood risk team um specifically over the
extent of coal vetting of a water course
so now there is one less dwelling and
that
part of the site is now open space with
the
water the open water course feature
retained there are some very minor
changes to address comments from
the highways officer and the designing
out crime officer
none of these changes were considered to
be of such a significant level
to necessitate a further period of
public consultation
normally if significant changes are made
that we feel the public and anyone who's
already commented on the application
needs to be made aware of
we would we would certainly run a
further public consultation
and that involves directly notifying
all neighbours and all those who have
previously commented that was not
considered necessary in this case
some letters of objection have been
received
due to some confusion over a statutory
consultation date that appear
that appeared on the website at the same
time members will hopefully see my email
that they were copied into explaining
the background to this
um but for the purposes of transparency
and in case anyone hasn't had a chance
to read that email
what happens when an application is is
confirmed as going to committee is that
the the relevant parish for town council
is notified
this is not a public consultation it's
to enable
the respective town or parish council to
determine whether a representative
should
appear at the committee this is
something that always happens and it's
something that's done on our internal
system
what this does is trigger an update to
the dates on the website
so it's a standard consultation date but
that resulted in a date being indicated
as the 15th of march which clearly is
after today's date
this was rectified the dates have been
um
corrected and the members of the public
who raised this is the concern have all
been notified
so i just wanted to explain explain that
context for you all
um moving on to the second verbal update
representations
the the application originally attracted
18 letters of
representation during the statutory
consultation period back in november
um we've received letters throughout
november december and
and january um since the publication of
the committee report we've had
approximately a further 25
letters representation some of them very
detailed
i have gone through all of these some
were received late last night
very late in the day yesterday um so
what i propose to do i mean a number of
the points
are reiterating points that have already
been raised that are already set out in
your agenda report
what i will do is just now right raise
anything that is
that is different um so
one point that has been raised is a
suggestion that accesses a material
consideration
at this reserve matters stage just to
clarify
access was did form part of the outline
application
and the primary access onto wooder road
has been approved in detail
also at the outline stage the principle
of
that level of development was assessed
in detail so there's a number of
supporting technical
documents including very detailed
transport assessment
um which which considered an approach
to access for the development
that included the principle of closing
up pit lane as was shown
on all of the indicative drawings and
um also that a point of access
would be secured onto pitt hill or pit
lane
and the actual detail of that access
because they
it wasn't the level of detail that would
necessarily show visibility
has been provided with this application
as required by a condition on the
outline
so insofar as access is not a reserve
matter
for this application there are still
matters of access that members need to
consider
for example the internal road layouts um
so
the the east-west link through the road
through the development the internal
highway networks
and the county highways officer has
commented on this
moving on other comments include a
suggestion that
the development is over development too
many houses on the site
that it constitutes an unsympathetic
layout and design
creating no sense of place there are
specific technical comments in regards
to surface water drainage
inadequacies these this is obviously a
technical matter and this comment will
be forwarded to
the flood risk team for the purposes of
discharging the relevant conditions
the physical capacity of pit hill pit
lane
in terms of traffic generation is raised
but as i
indicated earlier that principle has
already been established that is not a
reserve matters consideration
having said that the um the impacts on
pit lane
in terms of any consequential layout
impacts such as the fact that the east
way
east west link cuts through pit lane
that that is an impact on pit lane that
can be considered under the layout and
it's part of this reserve matters um
further comments suggest there's a lack
of a coherent open space strategy
inadequate structural planting that the
lap so the local area for players
inadequate that a leap
is needed um a maintenance
and management schedule that's
enforceable for the open space and
landscaping is required
somebody has raised that the lap is
above a drainage feature which could
affect the ability to plant trees
um the that the tree planting is
insufficient to replace the trees that
have been lost on the site this is with
reference
to um sort of maintenance and tree
felling that took place back in october
we've also received late yesterday a
chair a letter from the chair of
the battle of northern um
this letter has three points to it
one relating to archaeology and the
adequacies of the
written scheme of investigation the
written scheme of investigation has been
developed
by the applicant's consultants and
liaison with the county archaeologist
the county our county archaeologist has
provided comments which are set out in
the committee report
however this is a matter that was
considered that outline and is also
subject to an outline condition
so that element of the objection that
the comments will be provided to the
county archaeologist to see if there is
any implication
in terms of the discharge of the
condition the other two points
first one relates to the impact on the
historic landscape
and a suggestion that there is not
sufficient
open space retained to reflect that
historic landscape
and and then finally safe pedestrian
access and egress
with reference to pit hill lane and
specific reference to
battlefield walks that take place with
up to 30 people walking the length of
pitt hill
um so that's that one there was a
further very late representation that i
believe you were all copied in on so you
will have seen
um the objector has requested it to be
read out in detail but having discussed
this with our solicitor
we obviously have um a procedure whereby
speakers can ask
to have um statements read out so
what i will do is summarize and most of
the points have already been covered
they're also covered in my report
because they reiterate previous comments
in terms of anything that's that's new
the comments do pick up on
specifically the level of open space
provision and
highway impacts on pit lane and then
finally a further comment has been
received
raising sort of general concerns over
impacts on trees and wildlife
however the the objector has provided a
series of photos
and unfortunately the committee
presentation has already been um
prepared in any event the photos are
of a series of tree stumps just to
demonstrate the trees that were cut down
back in october
and an indication of these all being
roughly 50
millimeters in diameter um
sorry 500 millimeters in diameter this
is something that sits outside of the
planning
system but i did just want to raise that
i had received those photos so you're
aware
um so that's the update in terms of
representations
statutory consultees the only update i
have is that i've just had some further
correspondence from historic england
you will see in the committee report
that reference is made to
the um the impacts on tapeley house
which is
within north devon district which was
considered at outline stage
and we did engage with north devon
council's conservation officer and
historic england on that
historic england have just provided a
further comment to confirm they
they feel no need to be involved at this
reserve matters stage or to provide
further comments
so the impact in terms of tape me has
been
assessed to outline um open space scheme
also as indicating the committee report
we have now received an open space
scheme
which is something that's specifically
required in the section 106 agreement
but the that specific particular clause
does require it to be provided with the
reserve matters
what the open space scheme does very
usefully it consolidates
much of the information that's been set
submitted under separate sort of
headings so
the soft landscaping scheme the open
space strategy
elements of the landscape environmental
management plan it also includes a very
detailed management plan maintenance
plan for all of the landscaping
um this is something that was raised in
a recent representation
and um it's it's a document that
essentially doesn't doesn't add anything
new but it consolidates everything
and then finally in terms of conditions
and plans
um given we have now received the open
space scheme if my members are
minded to approve the application i
would recommend a condition be included
to
excuse me to secure the open space
scheme
and that the wording of that condition
would be agreed between
officers and the chair and vice chair
and that would give us a much more
robust position in terms of securing
landscaping
and maintenance of that landscaping in
the open space and there are just two
plans that need to be changed um
one plan is referred to as 0632 209 this
should be 309
that reflects the removal of plot 59
from the scheme
and finally drawing reference 201 needs
to not be on
the report that relates to a discharge
of condition
matter in terms of off-site drainage so
that that's all of the verbal updates
so i'll now run through the presentation
um
members obviously visited this site when
we when the outline was considered
um the the red app the red line for this
reserve matters application is
consistent with the outline
the site extends to approximately 3.75
hectares
it's to the south of apple doors north
east of northern
it's bound to the west by churchill way
wooder road is immediately to the south
pit lane which becomes pit hill
dissects the site through through the
center running in a south to north
direction
there are open fields and residential
properties surrounding
surrounding the site it is within
walking distance of ecuador centre both
via pitt hill
and also to walk around the slightly
longer route which is churchill way
public transport routes are available
along churchill way with bus stops to
the west of the site
this is an aerial photo which which
shows the the red line
corresponding with the the application
um location plan
the site as you can see is currently
green field um
it's enclosed by hedgerows hedge banks
trees of various quality
there is a hedge bank that does go
through the centre of the site
it is within flood zone one there's no
statutory
landscape or heritage designations that
affect the site
the western field um a butting churchill
way
is relatively flat and then as the site
moves on the other side of pit lane
and falls eastwards there is a slope
down towards the estuary
um in terms of existing built form on
the site there is an existing stable
building which is in
the sort of north northeast corner of
the western field
the site does form an allocation part of
an allocation within the local plan
um under policy nor seven and is within
the development boundary for apple door
that allocation as you as you're all
aware um
seeks to secure 130 dwellings across a
larger site
this application relates to the bottom
southern
largest section of that allocation um
the for your information
the local planning authority currently
has a proposal in
in outline for 27 dwellings on the
majority
of the remainder of that allocation and
that has also been called to committee
and will come
before committee in the next month or so
at the outline stage the the council
instructed an independent
landscape expert to assess the the the
landscape visual impact assessment that
was submitted
the the images that were contained
within that assessment were useful and
were shared with members at the outline
stage so i thought it would be helpful
just to show a few of these again
to show the site in its wider context so
just for use of reference the red is the
application site
the blue is the remainder of the
allocation so just working through
these views this is a view from from
tapeley
so um it is obviously
as i've said earlier north devon council
and historic england are haven't
commented on this reserve matter stage
and
any impact on on tape was was considered
at the outline stage
this is the view from the bidner
footpath so you can see the
the blue the remainder of the allocation
just sort of
sloped quite steeply to the north and
then the the application site is here
in the red lower down
this is the view across from new road
insto the site
the application site can't be seen in
any of those views as shown here
whereas the rest of the allocation can
and then finally this is a view from
windmill lane
which which shows the very eastern part
of this application site being the most
prominent certainly in this view
with the western site being much more
contained
the independent consultant also prepared
this helpful
aerial image which highlighted the
respective landscape sensitivities of
the
of well the wider allocation but the the
application before you today relates
just to that southern section
so you'll see from this assessment that
the western field is identified as being
a visually contained area so much less
sensitive in landscape terms
the the darker shading indicates less
sensitivity
so as you move to the eastern field that
very eastern
end is noticeable in views from the east
so not to such an extent as the northern
part of the allocation but
it is the most sensitive part of this
site
so now just moving through some photos
sort of more localized photos of the
site
this is a photo showing the boundary
onto churchill way
um it is a sort of existing hedge bank
you can see the public
footpath that runs along that road
next slide this is just moving down to
the corner with wooder road there are
some trees around that corner
and work their way around the bend um
there have been concerns raised
separately to this planning process
about tree removal
back in october november and you can see
some of the tree stumps
tree stumps there next slide please
and again this is just looking over from
churchill way into the site showing the
boundary
and the remaining trees along that bound
that hedge boundary with wooder road
this is the point of access from church
your way onto wooder road and just shows
that that corner
which has sort of a hedge bank with with
some retained trees within it next slide
and again this is now looking from
wooder road at that tree boundary this
is the western field now still
it's like so as we move along the
western field this shows pit lane
the junction of pit lane from wooder
road and
next slide and then these like
these slides just show the wood the wet
the western field itself so this is just
showing
inside the field that boundary with
wooder road
and now panning around that shows the
churchill way
beyond and the properties onto churchill
way
and then panning around again this is
the residential property sited to the
north of the site
and finally this is the the eastern end
of the western field you can see the
stable block
that is that is will be removed right
through the development
moving across now this is um pit lane
um there would be a new east west road
through the development which would sort
of truncate
pit lane at the top very top bit that
you can see here
the lane other than that would be
retained with hedge banks it would
become
a green a green router a footpath
and subject to the separate traffic
regulation order process
next slide please so this now shows the
relationship of pit lane looking across
to the eastern fields
next side and this is looking down now
into the eastern foot part of the site
so you can see the site slopes away the
hedge boundary
beyond um has some trees within it
next slide please and this shows the
the site now down towards the cops of
trees that would be retained and form
part of the public open space
excellent this is the view looking at
the eastern field from wilder road
next slide now panning down
until you get down to the bottom at
wooder road where you can see the cost
of trees again
next slide again there's a more detailed
look at the lower end of the eastern
field
you can identify the trees that would be
retained there would be a public right
of way that would
that would a public pedestrian access
would be achieved there
next slide and this is now looking back
upward a road with the trees on the
right
next slide and this is wooder road
with the the application site on your
right and this is where the main
principal access would be and finally
this is
pit hill so this is the bend where the
point of access would come on to pitt
hill
um immediate on the right the hedge row
that's just in the foreground here
the the site we currently have an
outline application in for is
is just located in there so moving on to
the plans now
um at outline stage there were a series
of parameter plans that
were provided a condition was included
on the outline permission
which required a detailed design code to
inform the reserve matters application
that has come in with this with this
reserve matters application
i just wanted to highlight a couple of
ways in which the parameter plans have
been developed to inform the layout
so this shows roots and movements
through the development
and with the red route being the primary
route through the primary act point of
vehicular access shown by the arrow on
wooder road
there is then what's known as a
secondary street which is the orange
street which would
go sort of east to west slightly up to
the north tertiary streets are
identified in yellow which would have a
much more sort of
residential feel just to access those
dwellings
um the the point where the new east-west
link
cuts across pit lane would become a
feature space
that's identified in purple and then the
footpaths are shown in green so with
that part of
pit lane becoming being retained in its
form but being restricted to pedestrian
access
there would also be two points of
pedestrian access onto churchill way
as well next slide please looking at
densities across the site
um this is split quite clearly between
the western field and then the eastern
fields to the
other side of pit lane the media
medium density development is proposed
on the very western field predominantly
two stories
and then that density is much lower in
the more sensitive part of the site
so the lvia assessment and our
independent assessment highlighted that
very
eastern section as being the most
sensitive and you know do bear in mind
with these parameter plans that they
still show that
plot that plot 59 being in place whereas
there's actually more open space on that
side now
next slide please this shows building
heights across the site so
two-story predominantly on the western
more visually contained field
and then a mix of one story and 1.5
story across the eastern fields
and the most sensitive part of the site
very
top north eastern corner you'll see
there are three one-story
dwellings there next slide please
and finally in terms of sort of
character area and legibility
the the app the design code proposes one
character area for the whole development
however the dwellings that are marked
with a red star on here have a slightly
different architectural treatment
whether that be something subtle like
the addition of a chimney
slightly different materials just to add
some legibility at key
visual points of the site there is also
a variety of building type
with the range in in heights and
designs as well so there is some
distinction albeit within one
one character area next slide
so this is the proposed planning layout
um
this is as per the plan that was amended
and uploaded on the 16th of february
you'll see on the eastern side there is
now a larger area of green space with
the watercourse running
um through that's that's you know
considered a benefit of the scheme
the this layout has evolved from the
parameter plans
and and is consistent with the the
design code
it's also evolved in connection with the
various technical studies that
were submitted at outline but also in
response to conditions on the outline
commission
the application proposes 88 dwellings
predominantly two and three bed
units there are nine four bed units as
well
um the i've already described the
distinction between the two story and
the one one and a half story
um as established at the outline the
main vehicular access is from wooder
road to the south
that has been approved um
the the principle of access onto pit
hill is was established at the outline
and um both in terms of um
the the closure of pit lane but also the
vehicular axis into there
the detail of that however is included
in this application
um the affordable units
will be four affordable houses they are
shown on the western field
you see there are three pink dots and a
blue dot so it's the kind of
north eastern corner of the western
field there are two two bed units two
three bed units and that corresponds
with the section 106.
um parking would be provided as at least
two spaces per unit
and refuse collection is provided as
well within the rears of the dwellings
so that
there wouldn't be bins to the fronts of
the dwellings
there is also a substation that's
required so that is down
a joist adjacent to the retained cops of
trees
down in the southeast corner that is now
to be accessed from within the
development um
our line stage it was indicated it would
be from wooder road but that now
comes from within the development next
slide please
i'll just run through the house types
now so this is the open market two bed
unit
um these would be predominantly located
within the western part of the site and
there would be
28 so no this is the full bench unit
sorry excuse me
nine there'll be nine of these
predominantly located within
the western part of the site next slide
these are the two beds um open market
units there'll be 28 of these again
located within the western field
and this is one of the bungalow house
types the two bed bungalow
um there will be 18 of these next slide
three bed bungalow there'll be seven of
these
then there are two house types which
have sort of a room in the roof so
they're 1.5 storeys these are
all three bedroom units there'll be 24
of these in total and they're
there there's like two slightly
different iterations so this is one of
the house types
next slide it's slightly slightly
different this the other house type
next slide and then just the affordable
units to finish their these are the two
bed
affordable units and then next slide
shows the three bed affordable units
and so moving on the design code
includes a very detailed pallet of
materials
um this the scheme proposes all the
dwellings to be
um have render walls indicative colours
are shown here
with some having varying elements of
weak on stone and grey there would be
gray tiles
with a combination of red and gray ridge
tiles
you can see there's different sort of
details in terms of the
the dormer windows that would be in the
room in the roof dwellings
and different chimney types as well
plinths
which are all be painted black um a
condition is recommended on
should members be minded to approve
their proposal that
samples of all the materials be be
provided prior to them being installed
just so that
officers can be satisfied that they're
appropriate for the site but on the face
of it this seems
reason reasonable palliative materials
next slide
there's also a lot of detail in terms of
doors and window details
with doors predominantly being black
railings and wall colorings indicated
there as well and then specific window
details so the design code
provides a lot of information that then
feeds into the design of the houses
next slide and this just shows some of
the streets
so the top one is the street scene
fronting churchill way
the two-story um larger dwellings at
this part of the site
the central street scene is fronting
wooder road
and there's a combination of two-story
properties room in the roof and
bungalows
and then over at the eastern side the
three bungalows
with one room in the roof following the
slope down the land
this is the most sensitive part of the
site so this is the view looking back
into the development from
those dwellings on the east next slide
um this this plan not terribly clear but
it's just to show that there would be
a range of materials across the sites
and the different colored dots which you
can just sort of faintly see so you can
see the yellow
the sort of brown color and the blue it
just shows that that render
those those that palette palliative
materials would be varied across the
site so
to give some distinction and that just
gives a feel for how that would work
across the site
next slide
boundary treatments of course very
important particularly in the public
fronting parts of the development any
public-facing boundary would either be
a render wall or a stone wall where
there's that where it's protecting a
private amenity space there were
lower similar walls proposed for public
fronting
areas and some of those featuring
railings as well
timber fencing would be just restricted
to
less visible areas and certainly rear
gardens next slide
this just shows the varying garaging
plans across the site
there is a combination of parking provos
but in terms of the garage buildings
there's
there's different different types but
they follow a similar
similar designs
similarly there is some cycle and bin
storage units that would go up and they
take the form of a simple timber shed
and finally these are the designs for
the the substation which is at the
bottom
southeast corner of the site and as
indicated it will be accessed from
within the development
so moving on to open space this is the
open space strategy plan
which highlights the different areas of
open space their quantities and what
their characters would be
um the the provision of open space at
this reserve matters stage is very much
driven by the section 106 associated
with the outline
and the the section 106 included a
formulaic approach to
establishing that quantity based on
policy dm10
um so in working through what that
requirement would be and this is based
on the
89 dwellings it would require 6
396 square meters um
and just slightly more 6398 square
meters are being provided in total
um that's obviously more now there's one
less dwelling but a great area of open
space
the typologies that policy dm10 requires
normally includes allotments and
also includes formal sport and wreck
provisions
um in this case partly due to viability
but primarily due to the the landscape
character and the need for
green infrastructure natural amenities
space
space the the section 106 adjust those
typologies with the focus being
whatever the generated need is for play
space and then the remainder being
natural green amenity space
um there have been some concerns raised
over the provision of a lap as opposed
to a leap
and the planning policy team have looked
at this and applied policy dm10
the the lap which is located centrally
within the central green
is a hundred square meters that is what
is generated by policy dm10
so a lap is a local area for play that
wouldn't even
require it being equipped this
this was discussed with the applicant in
light of the objections and officer
concerns
and that lap whilst remaining 100 square
meters is now to be equipped
and it also needs to be look at looked
at in the context of the wider
open space offer so the cops of trees in
the southeast corner
and the feature immediately around that
will will include a series of play on
the way features
um which would continue throughout the
the wooder road linear greens and then
the churchill way
wooder road and pit hill green area the
concept of play on the way is
you know a variety of play equipment
would would so people can enjoy
walking around these in connecting
interconnecting spaces
um the open space area in the top north
corner which is now bigger
the northeast corner that has the
watercourse tree planting
and also some benches so it has a
slightly different feel to it
the quantity of open space is in
complete compliance with the section 106
in fact more there is an over provision
and there is an over provision of play
space as well
um so whilst you know the the concerns
raised by objectives are understood
it's not possible to request a leap for
this scale of development
against our current policies next slide
moving on to open space there is a very
detailed open space landscaping plan
this this has a variety of features to
it
the focus has been retaining hedgerows
where possible
so the areas on the very eastern side
and the
southwestern side where which are
identified in red
they represent um native hedge banks
that will be infilled and reinforced so
there'll be additional tree planting
additional native species planting just
to bring those hedge banks up to
a much better standard so they are to be
retained but also enhanced
um the wooder road indicates a hedge
bank to be
retained fronting wooder road with some
tree planting within that
the the hedge banks along pit lane will
be retained
except for where the the access route
needs to go through
front gardens are a mixture of
ornamental shrub planting
ornamental hedges and all of the details
of
very concise details and planting
schemes have been provided
there would be significant enhancements
to the woodland planting
um and that would become a feature
that's publicly accessible
and additional trees planted all through
the eastern section of the site
the tree planting is a combination of
sort of native trees which are the
larger
symbols and they tend to be around the
open spaces and the
outer edges of the site ornamental trees
are proposed within
the lap and also within the sort of
central feature space
the this provision of open space and
landscaping is consistent with the lvia
mitigation measures that were
established at the outline stage
certainly when looking at that protect
more sensitive section on the eastern
side
there would be the enforced tree
planting and also a very low density and
significant open space
this just shows the the types of
features for the open space areas of the
types of seating bins
etcetera tree pits um these are all very
deep these are detailed in the open
space scheme
will be secured via the suggested
condition
and this slide shows the the equipment
that would be secured so the open space
scheme would secure
all of these different items of
equipment so in terms of the lap which
as i indicated doesn't actually require
equipment on it there would be a
provision arranged so there's
they will take a very natural aesthetic
so there would be a hill
slide balance beams stumps with log
seats
um undulating features
and that would all be fenced in the play
on the way equipment is also detailed
there and again ranges from
stumps with logs timber balance beams
stepping logs
monkey bars etcetera etcetera and all of
this would be secured
across the development via the open open
space scheme
finally just moving on to some of the
more technical details and respective
highways this sort of section 278
highway layout plan has been provided
the
the primary access onto wooder road has
already been agreed outline
and the principle of the access onto
lane has been agreed although condition
nine
of the outline does require the detail
of that access to be
included on the layout for the purposes
of the reserve matters
condition four of the outline requires
the phasing plan to
confirm timings and highlights the need
for a traffic regulation order for the
closure of pit lane
so that that's a separate process the
section 106 also secured mitigation when
some matters of highway impact were
considered um
furthermore north seven the allocation
does recognize the access and
pit hill as being required in terms of
what's before members for consideration
the internal highway layout is for
consideration
but it's the impact on the wider highway
network and traffic generation that
were obviously considered at outline
stage so
matt collins of the highway authority is
is available to answer questions later
but he has looked at this in detail
provided some initial comments raising
concerns over pedestrian
access routes which have all now been
addressed and his objection has been
removed
there's some very detailed sweat path
analysis and this just shows the um
the various points of access and the
need for vehicles to maneuver within the
site this is more for information
um but it is something the highway
officer has considered
next slide and there are further ones
so there's no objections on highways
next slide
this is a drainage strategy plan that
has been provided and this is this is
submitted pursuant to conditions on the
outlines the condition of 15 and 16 so
there is a separate discharge of
condition process
which has been um which we have
consulted with devon county's flood risk
team on and the environment
agency however it is prudent
for there to be an overlap with
consideration of reserve matters where
there might be an impact on layout
[Music]
so as indicated earlier we have one plot
due to concerns over the whole extent of
culverting
the watercourse coming down from the
north down to the south and eastern side
that has been addressed now and there is
in principle support for this on-site
drainage provision so this is as much as
anything to confirm that the layout that
is before you
has support from a drainage strategy
point of view as well albeit that will
be confirmed and approved by the
discharge of conditions
next slide this is a further plan that
has been taken from the submitted
construction environmental management
plan
a number of concerns raised in this
representation relate to wildlife
impacts
this is something that was discussed
considering in detail at the outline
stage there was an ecological impact
assessment
biodiversity position statement and a
condition included that requires
adherence to mitigation measures
sorry excuse me um i thought it would be
helpful just to highlight this so that
anything marked with a red is showing
features to be removed so if you're
looking at pit lane the red lines there
show the hedgerow to be removed
and there's a long red line coming down
through the development that is showing
the hedgerow to be moved
removed and the yellow lines show
features that are to be retained green
says enhancement so let's describe the
eastern boundary and the southwest
boundary
and then the new feature would be along
with a road to the south
with the the planting
so excuse me let's take a drink
so again there's a further condition
condition 20
on the outline which requires detailed
tree protection
measures to be agreed by condition um
we have received a tree survey
constraints plan
tree protection plans et cetera et
cetera there's a lot of concerns about
tree removal that has taken place that
is actually outside of the planning
process
so what we have before us is two
detailed tree protection plans which do
demonstrate
that truths can be protected and
hedgerows so this plan shows the
southwest corner
the red outline indicates that there
would be protection measures during
during construction
and there are also trees immediately
just to the north
of that western field it also shows no
build zones involving the hedge row
along pit lane let me just move on to
the next slide
and again on this side it shows the tree
cops being protected showing the red
line
and other areas that will be protected
there is actually a low level of tree
removal that would be required
and the overall impact would be a net
gain of trees on the site
so finally just to conclude and i set
out in the report
the material considerations in this
particular case are as follows so
firstly the principle of development and
the outline planning permission
these are set out in your agenda report
as much as anything just to set that
context
um it's important in terms of the level
of development that's coming forward on
site to make sure that corresponds with
what was approved to outline
the outline approved up to 110 it's
considered in light of the landscape
sensitivities but 88 is appropriate
the section 106 required affordable
housing that has been provided
that no ransom would be no ransom
position would be
enabled in terms of the further
allocation coming
forward the access has been improved to
allow that
and also an open space clean scheme
which which you have seen
um there
are various conditions on the outline
and these have all been detailed where
submissions have been
received um importantly
the layout that's before you and other
details have been formulated
um in can to be consistent with all of
those technical studies
um for example devon county flood risk
we have some changes were secured
to make sure they were happy there's no
conflict in that regard
um access was approved at outline stage
however the detail of pit hill is before
members as well today
and as well as the internal layout the
layout scale external appearance and
landscaping are all considered
acceptable
um as detailed in the report in terms of
other matters
ecology there's a number of concerns
about ecology um
we do have conditions in place the
curing mitigation measures
and a lamp and a semp so environmental
management plans for the construction
and
the post development stage these
are all in a so the landscape and layout
that has come forward is all in
association with the recommendations of
those reports
finally five-year land supply the
principle and number of dwellings has
already been established so this is not
a tilted balance decision that's before
members
however you know it should be noted that
approval of this and delivery of this
site will help
with delivering and addressing the
shortfall
um so finally these reserve matters
details relating to scale layout and
appearance and landscaping are
considered acceptable
and approval is recommended subject to
the the plan
changes and the
inclusion of a condition to secure the
open space scheme
thank you
well thank thank you very much helen for
a
a very concise presentation a long one
uh have that drink now and get his
throat settled down i've been
coughing and i've not been speaking on
this uh right well
now we go to the contributions of public
participation
part and if he's there peter steer is
there's nobody from the town council
from northern town council to speak
on behalf of northern town council so
peter steer is the first public speaker
and he's speaking against it
if you're a peter if you want to be
unmuted if
if tomorrow mutes you or you unmute
yourself you you have a prop
you know three minutes to present your
uh
opinion on this application
are you there peter hi can you hear me i
can hear you loud and clear yeah she's
three
three minutes thank you mr steer from
now
good morning chair ladies and gentlemen
if this application is approved
a community will be created with 88
dwellings some 200 people
including perhaps 30 children eligible
for the primary school
as well as possibly 150 or so vehicles
pit lane and pit hill is the quickest
way from this community to apple door
village
and the school shops pubs cafes etc
pit lane and pit hill are considered
here using two material considerations
firstly traffic generation far more
traffic
vehicular and pedestrian traffic will
result from the development than occurs
today
even if pit lane is closed it is the
shortest route to the primary school so
some
20 children plus parents could use pit
lane pit hill
twice maybe four times a school day
secondly highway safety much of pit lane
is a single carriageway with no footways
on pit hill there are intermittent
inadequate
footways with wider roads being reduced
in places by parked vehicles
the alternative route to the school and
village by the a386 or
churchill way is longer and requires two
crossings of the highway to keep on a
footway
there is some 20 meters with no footwear
at all
at the junction with stony lane so
significant traffic and safety issues
need to be resolved
before this application can be approved
moving on to surface water drainage
design
the submission by trace design is based
on the site being flat
that is the ground slope less than two
degrees
and consideration of a green field area
of just 1.9 hectares
that would become impermeable with
development
rather than the full site area of 3.75
hectares
trace design gives a discharge rate q
bar
of 5.3 liters per second into the main
drainage
on wooder road and a relative volume of
attenuation storage of
let us say 100. the submitted design
does not take into account either the
full site
area of 3.75 hectares
or that two-thirds of the site slopes at
four degrees or more
and the possible effect of runoff from
the field to the north of the site
between pit lane
and the football club if the submitted
design was built with a maximum
discharge rate kept at 5.3 liters per
second
then in then taking into account the
full site area
increases the relative storage
requirement from 100
to 175 the slope would
require 250 and the added field
raises it to 350. so with the submitted
design
manhole lids are in danger of popping
off
but with any one of these three
unaccounted for conditions
the overflow and flooding would be
disastrous
the present surface water drainage
design needs to be reconsidered
before planning approval can be given
thank you miss thank you mr steer for
your presentation
and comments thank you for that
right our next speaker against the
application is keith goodreads
if you're there mr goodread yes can you
hear me
yeah can you loud and clear and you have
three minutes
to present your views on this
application from now thank you
thank you good morning councillors i am
a local resident
and retired town and country planner
with over 30 years experience
i believe this application should be
refused for two important reasons
firstly on landscaping and green
infrastructure the local plan
requirements for the site are that it
should be developed and i quote
of a form that minimizes any loss of
landscape character of the surrounding
area
and also that the high quality design
will be achieved throughout the
development
which provides a reflection of the
area's historic character with an
emphasis on green
infrastructure delivery the layout of
the development within the site will
minimize any consequent landscape impact
particularly in respect to the area to
the north of woodrow road
the current layout does not meet with
these objectives given the poultry sum
of just 11 trees yes and i said again
just 11
trees within the main body of the site
excluding the boundary trees in the
stream area
on the eastern side of the site further
structural tree planting is required
within the main body of the site to
minimize the consequent landscape
impact of this large housing site and it
should not just be confined to the
boundaries
much of the site is on a prominent slope
and further landscaping in the form of
tree planting is essential
if the requirements of the look ban
policy are to be met
eleven trees are simply not enough
secondly the children's play facility is
inadequate and that is bounded on two
sides by roads
one of which is the main through route
for the site neither of these roads have
bookways adjacent to the play area
and the roads are also formed part of a
crossroads the pedestrian access to the
bay area is therefore considered to be
dangerous for both children and adults
in addition because of its location it
will be subjected to vehicle exhaust
pollution
which is known can have an adverse
effect on health
also because of its triangular shape it
results in two very narrow corners
of almost unusual play space furthermore
in order to meet the recognized fields
and trust more often referred to as the
national playing fields association six
acres standard for play provision a
local equipped area for play should be
provided for a site of this size
with a minimum activity area of around
400 square meters
not the 200 square meters proposed the
play space needs to be completely
relocated and designed
in order to meet with the local plan
national planning policy framework
requirements
children don't usually comment on
planning applications so it is up to us
to ensure that their needs are met
properly
so we must ensure children are given a
safe place to play
children are given a healthy place to
play and children are given
enough space to play the proposals sadly
fail
in all three respects on these two
issues i respectfully request you to
refuse this application
thank you very much
yeah you're muted
beggy pardon everybody i was muted
myself there because i was coughing
our next public contribution is from
graham hutton
in support of it and he's the applicant
mr hutton if you'd like to give your
three-minute presentation please
thank you very much and good morning
everybody i'm development director at
baker estates
and we own the land at appledore for
which you granted on approval last year
we've been really pleased to work
constructively with officers to develop
these reserve matters applications
before you today
and i'm pleased that the report is both
comprehensive and clear in its
recommendation for approval
the application is for just 88 homes but
of a mix almost
unheard of in new build development 34 2
bedroom
houses plus 55 bungalows many of which
are also two bed meaning that half of
the homes
have two bedrooms the remaining 10 are
small family four bedroom homes and this
directly responds to the community
feedback
which clearly desired homes to meet the
local need all other small homes will be
within the help debate by
price ceiling making them accessible to
local families and first-time buyers
and there's also an enormous need for
bungalows for our aging population
i mentioned it is just 88 homes and
you'll recall that the outline is for up
to 110.
once again this is a result of tailoring
the design to suit the local priorities
expressed through the public
consultation
developers are sometimes criticized for
cramming homes in but this development
is only 10 home per acre
slightly looser than many exemplar areas
of ecuador
but more importantly this density allows
space for quality landscaping and public
realm
and i mentioned the quality of the
public realm as another key aspect of
the outline was the requirement for a
design code to ensure that this quality
is secured in building and public spaces
the document includes a full review of
local buildings in ecuador to ensure
our new homes fit well and have
appropriate design detailing and i'm
delighted that your officers support the
approval of that detailed design code
another aspect is to ensure that the
higher parts of the land are populated
with the lowest buildings with respect
to the landscape
setting and because we propose bungalows
we've been able to do this so much more
sensitively than would otherwise have
been the case
despite accusations regarding the
chopping of trees
preparatory works were actually
undertaken with the full knowledge of
officers to remove trees with ash
dieback
ahead of the bird nesting season to
ensure it is possible to start building
this year
should you grant approval today and i
can confirm that we have also submitted
to discharge all the outline
pre-commencement conditions
although today is just those reserve
matters before you
there's one isolated point i'd like to
make very clear
outline stage that this development must
allow for the remainder of the
allocation to be delivered and i confirm
that our highways and infrastructure
provision will do exactly that
dcc have confirmed as much so i hope you
can detect my enthusiasm for the
development
i'm delighted that circumstances have
allowed us to propose a design of such
quality
at a density and with a mix that
responds to the local priorities
so i very much hope therefore that
members today will decide to approve
these reserve matters which would enable
the delivery of the homes and the
substantial section 106 package to begin
this summer
thank you very much for your time thank
you mr hartman thank you for your
presentation our final speaker
is board member for apple dog counselor
peter haynes
and you're not restricted to three
minutes council haynes
thank you chad it won't take much more
than that um
thank you chair good morning councillors
um
yeah just to as a preliminary but to
take up what the case officer said about
the
later amended amendments on the
documents
um we've heard our explanation
we've heard her explanation about the
date of 15th march
a number of residents locally have
expressed their concerns that
all this means that they haven't had
further opportunity to put in their
comments
um although um
the uh the change designs have been
taken out of the list because that was
an administrative era
there are however however still
amendments there on
to do with street scene tracking of
traffic drainage
layout landscape and flooding
flood routes so i put it to you or leave
it to you as a committee to consider
whether
you should be uh consider
deferring um consideration this
application
pending further comment on all these
amendments
um i'll leave it at that going on
to um there are concerns about the
actual planning application the revised
matters reserve matters um
i i must raise the matter of pit lane
again
um i'm reflecting huge local concern
about this
it's not a reserve matter but i'm
proposing to go on and suggest something
which relates to the internal road
layout
of the development which is in fact part
of our consideration today
i must seriously emphasize the concerns
about traffic
generated from the road development in
front of you onto the narrow route of
pit lane
which will result in a danger to
pedestrians and cyclists and
particularly children and parents
walking to school
something which is contrary to the local
planned policy
sto2c regarding promotion of walking and
cycling
and also national framework para109
regarding highway safety
i also pick up what helen smith said
about
pit lane being a walking route to
appledore well
i'll leave that up to you members to
consider
whether you would like a situation where
children and parents have to walk along
a very narrow road where there's a huge
amount of more
traffic generated sadly regarding these
issues with here yet one more example of
recent planning applications
of decisions which favor car use rather
than alternative transport
despite the environmental policy
provisions set out at the beginning of
the local plan
i and i suggest to members there's much
work to be done at the upcoming local
plan review regarding the process of
allocating development
sites and strengthening environmental
and climate plus
policies looking to when other allocated
sites which he joined the wooder
roadside to develop
i would urge planners to promote a
pedestrian and cycle plan
which will ensure safe access to outdoor
school
and village shops and services from all
those sites
including the site members are
considering today
and of course mr mr steer has said
that you need to consider this now for
this application
regarding pit lane um and as a revised
road layout within the development may i
suggest serious consideration as given
to blocking off access to pit lane from
the development
and to incorporating a turning point for
traffic coming from appledore
so that traffic cannot enter the site
while such a provision may not be able
to be incorporated in the present
application
because the need to allow access to the
yet to be developed second part of the
allocated site
i suggest there could be an opportunity
to create a turning point
when the outline application for the
second site comes before you
such a proposal to restrict use of pit
lane
would of course have to be subject to
local residents comments
but the traffic impact on this route is
so important that the whole issue needs
proper discussion and resolution
turning to issues under reserve matters
i asked members to now consider the
design of the proposed houses
policy naw seven governing allocation to
site states the development should be of
high quality
and should minimize any loss of
landscape character of the surrounding
area
while local plant policy sto4 states
that design
should respond to the characteristics of
the site
its wider context and the surrounding
area policies dm04
or dm08a state there should be an
improvement in the character and quality
of the area
and further i should remind members of
the need to ensure high standard of
design in the coast and estuary zone
of which the site forms apart given
these policies do members rarely think
that we've been presented with proposals
which conform to these policy
requirements
i submit the designs of what one would
expect from any suburban development
anywhere at the edge of towns and cities
in the uk
that they've been imposed on a highly
sensitive landscape
at this application site clearly the
applicants need to go back and produce a
scheme which more closely abides with
north sevens requirement
and that of other policies to minimize
landscape impact
turning to another reserve matter that's
landscaping and green infrastructure
i refer members against policies no our
policy
our seven governing the site which
states there should be provision of
areas of green infrastructure
providing opportunities for biodiversity
enhancement and
informal recreation focused on the south
of the site
i also refer to the local plan policy
sto3
um i and j
concerning incorporation of green
infrastructure and corridors
looking at the amended landscape plan
what do we see
we see dense blocks of housing and
streets and no areas of tree or shrubs
in between them to mitigate landscape
impact
just look at the number of trees
proposed to the middle of
the middle of the site we've been told
just eleven
israeli is not acceptable in terms of
policy requirement
and the applicant should produce a
revised plan which is in accordance with
these
especially given the number of trees
which have recently been felled on the
site
and the loss of biodiversity in this
respect i note a rare drop in enthusiasm
in the case officer is a report to this
committee
where she concludes that the landscaping
will create a reasonable amount of
mitigation to assist in reducing
landscape impact of the proposal
and will also help to soften the built
form
whilst creating a sense of place so she
doesn't exactly go overboard in her use
of the words reasonable and helps to
soften
as a further comment on infrastructure
and biodiversity and referring to the
boggy nature of the land
may i ask why hasn't a natural pond been
allowed for on the layout
which would enhance biodiversity and add
value for the residents
in this respect the contrast with the
environmental proposals
in the outlying application for the
other part of the allocated site which
is going to come before you in a
couple of months time does include such
a feature as well as others
so there's a notable contrast there
there has also been local concern the
felling of a large number of boundary
trees resulting in loss of wildlife and
casting doubt on the applicant's
commitments to achieving a net gain in
biodiversity
it's been pointed out that any
replacement trees will take years to
provide a carbon sequestration and
habitat provided by trees
which by the trees which have been
filled while the offsetting proposals
that ken proposed at kenworth valley
would fail to fully replicate what we've
what has been lost from the development
side
regarding the proposed play here in the
middle of the site it's been pointed out
that this should be of a larger
leap standard in his accordance with
national playing fields association
requirement
recommendations and it's also been
mentioned
that the triangular shape is not the
best shape to incorporate play equipment
i also refer to the bulky nature of the
play area which is surely not
appropriate
it's also dangerous for pedestrian
access given its sighting by main
thoroughfares
and the lack of footways and i submit
that because of its central position it
fails to effectively serve residents
living on the extreme eastern part of
the site
surely there should be another smaller
play area
or one or two players for these part for
one smaller play area for that part of
the development
in terms of climate change and
resilience i refer to policies
sdo 3g and st05
relating to developments in terms of use
of resources energy efficiency use of
renewables
and reduction of energy demand and i do
query how far the applicants have gone
to fulfill these policies
this is a clear environmental
requirement at the very heart of the
local sub
plan so i suggest members give this
matter full consideration
in conclusion i urge members to
recognize the high sensitivity
sensitivity of the development site and
to
refuse this this reserve matters
application
on the grounds of poor design
landscaping and green infrastructure
being an inadequate inadequate play
provision
and non-compliance with policies sto3g
and st05
thank you chair thank you councillor
haynes
right that's the last of our speakers um
so it now goes down to the committee to
discuss it
who would like to start the discussion
on this site
well i will do if nobody else wants to
i'll start the discussion on the site
then
there's two main issues for me uh whilst
we'll go go back to the outline
application which was approved for 110
dwellings members will remember on there
um an indicative plan showed three some
three-story blocks of flats on that side
i mean
this is a big vast improvement on what's
proposed on here the bungalows
i'm absolutely thrilled to bets that
we're going to get at last some decent
number of bungalows on the site which
enables the older population to downsize
freeing up family homes so the layout of
the site down from 110
to now 88 with the omission of that one
um in the stream corridor
is is it improvement there are two
things that do concern me
and one is that we are only getting this
lap when in the outline
application and i was only indicative we
were
shown a plan that showed two local areas
of
quit play on on the outline
so i'm i'm disappointed i don't think a
lap
with the poultry equipment proposed for
that
is good enough as a play area and it
only take it's only for children up the
age of about
six that whereas a leap
caters for children at the age of eight
and we need that on the site
i was looking at the plan and i thought
maybe the leak could be provided
at the top end of the stream corridor
there
over on the eastern side but it's not
good enough to just put a lap there and
i do take on the points
that have been raised about access being
right on the
main road through the site with no
footpaths either side of that play area
it's not an ideal position to have it
that would make a nice green area
the also the comments made on it these
attenuation crates are underneath that
site
the whole site is the largest
attenuation site
uh on the development uh two meters
dinner now i don't know what the trees
above
will be like to be able to grow on top
of that
question mark with me over that the
reserve matters
application looked at access and the
access was
discussed i remember from churchill way
into wooder road and from wooder road
the new access coming into this site
which was approved we didn't have any
detailed discussion
on the pet hill and well apart from the
fact that we're closing off
part of pit lane there but we didn't
have any detailed
plans to look at of the proposals where
it joins pit lane
and pit hill and i do accept there are
for me major issues with traffic
leaving this site and heading down pit
lane and pit hill
i'm i'm most unhappy about that i
noticed a town council
it's their number one objection that
cannot possibly accept the idea of
traffic coming into pet lane
this would be far too dangerous they
also further make the point about
the play area being too small i do
except we've got these linear play areas
throughout these walk through play areas
on the site
and there are plenty of footpaths
leading onto churchill way
from the western part of the site but
this issue of pit lane really does need
addressing and i'm surprised
on the policy dm05 highways
that we did not insist on a transport
assessment and travel plan
for this site i think we should have
require requested that
and we should have had one because that
would have addressed all the development
proposals that would give rise to
significant levels
of vehicular movement and are likely to
create or exacerbate
a particular traffic problem or have an
impact on the local highway
network must be accompanied by a
transport assessment and travel plan
so i'll ask that question of either
um well either sean
sean uh harrington can run
or um
helen can answer if you'd like to why
that wasn't requested
and i do i do realize with an outline
application which we've not
had before us for the for the rest of
the site
um and it might be possible to address
this plain pet hill issue
through that but i am disappointed it's
not been addressed with this application
i don't know if sean or helen would like
to comment on the
why we didn't request this transport
assessment and travel plan
yeah thank you chair i'll i'll respond
to your your various points if that's
okay
and it may be that that shawn harrington
and or matt collins
matt collins particularly on the highway
aspects might come in
just dealing firstly with the um open
space
provision as i indicated in my
presentation
the the level of open space that's
proposed on site is very much
determined by the legal agreement that
was attached to the outline
and in turn that is linked back to our
policy dm10
um a leap so locally a quick set
equipped area for play
is not a need for that is not generated
by this scale of development
i think you would need between three or
four hundred dwellings to
to be able to require that under policy
dm10
so the level of provision that is
provided
and that need that is generated is is a
local area
for play and the local area for play
doesn't need to be equipped
um through discussions and trying to
take a more sort of flexible pragmatic
approach to the provision of the open
space
that central local area for play is now
identified as being 200 square meters
within the open space
plan and it would be equipped
with the the range of provisions that
were shown
the it's important to look at the open
space in the wider context and also
indeed the requirements of policy north
seven
i think to have just one contained area
of open space
um within the site would would lead to a
greater density in other parts of the
site and i think the response of this
layout
in terms of blending that open space
with the development and the lowest
density of development is is the right
way to go in this case
um the the play on the way concept is
actually supported for this
location and that overall level of
provision
so when you factor in the the play
equipment on the play and the way
um is actually more than they're
required to provide so i
you know there would be a risk in in
members
requiring a leap because there is no
policy or 106 basis for that
in terms of the trees and the the
underground crate on
on the lap and yeah i must confess i'm
not not an expert to be able to
to go into any detail on that i what i
would say is those trees are shown along
the very boundary
predominantly i think and they are
ornamental trees as opposed to the
larger native trees
um but that is certainly something that
you know details could be required for
how that would work as part of a
condition
um of alternative trees to be provided
if if necessary
um moving on to the issue with the
impact on pit lane
or pit hill so the the access strategy
at outline stage there was a transport
assessment
um accompanying travel plan all of those
details were provided
and they were all assessed by by the
highway authority
as as the experts in those areas um
the the assessment into the highway
impacts
resulted in no need for an offsite
contribution towards high improvements
there were however improvements in
respect of the crossing at the primary
school
and the parking space as well off
churchill way
those matters and the ability to secure
and assess that impact on a wider
highway network is an outlying principal
matter
the reserve matters stage and
particularly the four reserve matters
that are before members
would not require a transport assessment
to be provided just
to assess the impact on pit lane that
would have been considered
comprehensively
in respect of the outline and the
information that was submitted
but also in the actual allocation of and
the
um formulating of policy north seven
which specifically refers to access onto
pitt hill and improvements to pitt hill
as well
um it there is a slight confusion
in terms of the detail of the access
onto pitt hill
the the principle of that access and the
need for the traffic regulation order
that is all set out in the outline
the committee report but also the
through conditions
um in terms of the timing for the tro
and the closure of pit lane being
required so it's therefore
clear that that was assumed to happen
and that that point of access would come
on to pitt hill hence the requirement
for prevention of any ransom of that
development to the north and indeed
being mindful of this being part of a
wider allocation
so i would say that the principle of
that access and that access being a
matter that was considered
an outline is established that the
reason
for the the condition i can top my head
i can't remember which condition it is
that
that approves the access on toward a
road but requires
the detail of the further points of
access is simply that the highway
officer and i'm sure he will confirm
this
didn't feel there was quite the level of
detail just to check that that was
that it was technically acceptable and
that that would need to come forward
with the outline with sorry with the
reserve matters in light of the layout
um i don't know whether it probably
would be be helpful for matt collins to
provide some further comments chair if
you think that would be helpful
yeah if he wants to comment yeah but
helen you're saying that there was a
transport
assessment and travel plan outline there
was a yes certainly a transport
assessment which would have included
sort of sustainable transport provisions
and that's the document that would have
been
looked at in detail by by the highway
authority
transport assessments cover a number of
areas they you know they look at
the impact on key junctions they look at
the highway network
the ability for pedestrians and
proximity to services so
a transport assessment was provided and
outlined stage is
the appropriate stage for that it would
not be appropriate to start assessing
questions it's just i don't remember
seeing the outline applications
okay well i'm sure i i'm sure matt
collins would
who did review that document it might be
helpful for him just to
to provide some clarification on that
thank you heather
matt if you'd like and then i'll bring
cancer the lock in certainly
chairman um as helen says there was a
transport
statement um provided with the outline
application i've just looked up on the
on your
planning website is runs to 48 pages
with appendices
including um information on
vehicle collisions in the area and
assessment of various junctions
um the time to look at that impact has
passed and that is with the
outline application that has is an
established
principle through through the outline
the detail
of the junction onto pit hill is a
consideration that we we need to
think about as if if the site progresses
there's also an application on the land
to the north a live application at the
moment
and should both and or one or one and or
the other
application be approved
we need to work with whoever develops
those sites if that happens
to come up with a solution that works so
we we are
flexible in terms of the works on the
ground when
we get to that point and we it is
people in my team that's their job to if
they need to bang the bank heads
together between the two developers and
get them to build something that works
and is is safe
that will be subject to further road
safety audits
if if and when they when they proceed
um and and things can be amended in the
future
and in in terms of i think it was
councillor haynes's suggestion of the
turning point
um and any any closure of
pit hill or pit lane that is subject to
separate legislation
and um outside of the planning
committee's control
thank you mark right i'll bring
councillor lock him
give him wait impatient there counselor
lock
um uh mcdonald's answer some of my
points so
what you're saying that is when the
application comes in for the
area north of this site road
improvements
um could be made at that stage because
we're always told that we've got to look
what's in front of us so if that's not
in front of us now
we could consider further road
improvements when that second
application comes in is that correct
um there is a live application at the
moment
on that site i'm not sure whether it has
been called in or will will come to
committee
um we have to think about
both applications as if
the other one both is there and isn't
there in the event that
it does or doesn't go ahead in all the
different
possible situations so you have to
consider what's before you
um but my role is to make sure that
whichever
does or doesn't happen depending on your
decisions could be built
legally and i'm saying that in this case
that is possible if you approve the
application
right thank you for that um and i know
that um have no objections following the
revised layout
of this application but on page 39
on the first paragraph it mentions
footpaths
as the ownership of those footpaths
being determined
i i believe some of the paths will
remain in a private management company
um and are possibly within a public open
space so that they would be public
um unfortunately through the planning
process you
cannot force the developer to make any
part of that site public highway you
cannot force them to put it forward for
adoption
and they have they have provided a plan
um of what they would offer for adoption
and we will go through that process
when we get to it right and
thirdly then with regards to the section
106 payments
um i can understand the education
contributions and there's thirty
thousand towards the step across
avador primary school and thirty
thousands of biodiversity enhancements
then there's fifty thousand pounds to
improve on-road parking in the local
area
so what are you going to spend fifty
thousand pounds on for parking
there was considerable detailed
discussion around the section 106
wording at the time of the outline
the there is a scheme that the developer
will be building
just uh near the bloody corner between
there and the um
the town hall yeah where there's a
considerable on street parking and has
been a long term
um aim to put some parking spaces on the
verge
um built properly uh
for for those residents uh or for the
general public
um the developer should be building that
however there is wording that if the
estimate is
more than fifty thousand they would be
paying that contribution
for us to build it instead
right and then going away from highways
i think the one big plus of this
application
is um the amount of bungalows which i
think is 49
and um because you know committee
members have been and members of the
public have been crying out for
more bungalows to be constructed and
there are also 28
two veteran houses which will enable
local residents to
um purchase and be first-time buyers on
the
property ladder so i will wait and see
what other committee members say
thank you chair anchor council a lot
counselor christy
thank you um can i just start off by
asking helen something um helen you very
briefly mentioned the archaeological
investigations
uh we do have something in our agenda
today it's on page 42. it's a paragraph
about it but this is just a reprint of
what's on our website which is dated
november
2020. can you update me on what's
happened about the archaeological
investigations yep certainly councillor
christie
so the the archaeological
um considerations um primarily on this
related to the outline stage so at the
outline stage there was
alcohol archaeological details provided
the county archaeologist was consulted
he
recommended his condition which i
believe is condition 19 on the
outline permission which requires a
written scheme of investigation
so that's that's quite a common
condition
on outline schemes like this um
and that that responds to the fact that
no significant
findings of archaeological artifacts
were were made
however this written scheme of
investigation this process has to be
followed throughout the
throughout the construction process so
the comments
i think from the archaeology section is
a response to this reserve matters
application
um where you can see the officer is
referring back to condition 19.
i believe there have been archaeological
investigations on site which i think are
pursuant to the written scheme of
investigation
that is something that is monitored by
the county archaeologist
and that program has to continue
throughout throughout the whole
construction process
for the purposes of this reserve matters
um
it's the the consideration of that and
the appropriateness of that written
scheme of investigation is pursuant to
the discharge of condition 19
of the outlying permission so we have
received that document
written scheme of investigation the
county archaeologist has given his
support to that document
and encourages that condition to be
discharged and it would therefore mean
that
that discharge of condition would sit
alongside
the outlying the reserve matters and
it's something that would have to be
adhered to
throughout the process um the comments
received late yesterday do raise some
concern over the
i think the extent of metal detecting
work that was undertaken
and given no decision has been made on
the acceptability of the written scheme
of investigation that those comments
would most appropriately be shared with
with the county archaeologist so that's
something that
um the archaeologist the county
archaeologist has been consulted on this
application
that you know as can be seen in the
response
um he's more interested with compliance
and discharge of condition
19.
thank you um yeah as i say that is
actually just a reprint of the november
2020 comment on our website so
i'm not sure what the update is but
anyway i'll move on uh can i i'd like to
make a general point
about this development because it's
something that i've raised before
this is an allocated site in our local
plan hence
it was given planning permission last
time i think
um and yet once the
investigation starts the developer
suddenly finds this is enormous problem
with drainage and we've got a lot of
material in our agenda today about
drainage
and this is the reason apparently the
expense of that why
there was going to be no affordable now
is going to be five percent
nowhere near the 30 percent we try and
get because
um we really do need as a council to
have a look at this because
we are allocating sites without
apparently
much sight investigation at all as soon
as developer looks at the site and
what they do they identify all the
problems
and we seem to have shot ourselves in
the foot again and this is something
that we really do need to look at when
we come to rewrite our local plan we
don't allocate any new areas
unless there's been serious site
investigation
because otherwise we'll never get
affordable houses
um moving on to this site itself um
it's a problem because we've seen all
the maps today
and they all show the site in great
detail and so on but if you look at the
site
in terms of how it sits with apple door
it's isolated it's like plonking down
an estate in the middle of the open
countryside
um after the houses i think council
haynes mentioned
i can't see any local distinctiveness in
them at all
i hesitate to use the words box standard
but
some people might um
the other thing is and again i have to
refer back to the first meeting i was a
bit surprised to hear there's going to
be some
offset in terms of tree planting and so
on to the kenworth valley
now the kenworth valley is actually my
ward i have asked
where is his offset site gonna be
nobody's told me nobody seems to know
and given that torridge owned quite a
lot of land in the kenworth valley and
so did the british trust and i better
declare an interest there
um i'm i'm just
perplexed is where where are they
talking about
um i have asked for this and i can't get
any detail at all
um i would like an answer to that if
that's possible thank you
thank you thank you councillor christie
um
i don't know if helen can answer yeah
yeah and
plant him down in the chemist valley
yeah um
unfortunately councillor christie i
can't give you an answer here and now um
on that um and i do recall you being
very interested in this at the outline
stage
so that the nature of the biodiversity
offsetting that was secured through
consultation with the north devon
biosphere
so projects where where a site can't
provide the
the 10 net gain on site we do
look for an element to be secured off
site and that is what happened in in
this case at the outline stage
the exact locations of of where that
sort of circle 30 000
pounds is going to be directed to i
haven't got an answer right here now but
it is something i can try and find out
for you councillor christie and
and provide an update to you um if
if that's okay um i think just drawing
on
council christie's other other points i
think you know
the reference to moving forward and
looking at the allocation of sites i
think as often says we would
you know 100 agree with that um
and you know any any comment on the site
and how it sits in the context of its
environment um yes it is a valid point
but that's more for the allocation and
outline stage we
it benefits from the allocation it does
have that outline permission
so um yes i could just leave that that i
will try and find something out
and correspond directly with councillor
christie
thank you helen just before i bring
councillor watson in to clear up this
archaeological question that councillor
christie
raised condition 19 in the outline
finishes by saying this pre-commencement
condition
is required to ensure that the
archaeological works are agreed
and implemented prior to any disturbance
of archaeological deposits by the
commencement of preparatory
and or construction work so i've heard
what you said in
answer helen about the
devon county archaeological in agreement
but
this work needs to be done before
anything happens on the site
so a full archaeological study is that
correct
yes yes being completed not not just
that when the
digging foundations they come across a
skeleton or
turns some artifact up yes
counselor that's that's correct so the
written scheme of investigation it's
the the document itself sets out what
that program of works will involve and
how that will
evolve with the scheme and all of that
has to be agreed prior to the
commencement of development but the
written scheme of investigation will
also include
include various stages that have to that
have to be adhered to
it's both a pre-commencement and
compliance condition
um it is it is something that the the
monitoring of that
does tend to fall with the county
archaeologists but we do liaise with
them and
receive updates so that we know what
point conditions have been complied with
thank you right councillor watson
thank you chairman i've waited quite a
long time
my first question actually was going to
be to ellen because
i was going to ask what sort of trees
that were cut down
but but now i know that they're ash that
that's fine
because i understand all about josh at
the moment i've got a hundred nod trees
at the back of me
ready to be cut down by the forestry
commission
and and i know that if ash
isn't cut down within the first couple
of years it becomes very dangerous
uh and brittle so yeah that's that was
one point
thanks for that um as a as a site
i don't think this site is a dense
uh a dense site at all we have
the the amount of bungalows that come in
into this site
um and we all know that bungalows take
more space up than houses
it's fantastic i think it's an extremely
good site
in fact it's one of the best sites i've
seen for a few years
and when you compare okay let's go think
about dad nil
how many houses are going there they
will look mainly all the same
these this site is a really really good
mix of properties
i think it's been laid out extremely
well
as the site goes and for me
i'll pr i'm going to propose that we
approve this site
thank you chairman thank you councillor
watson
um nobody else has got their hand up so
i will just make the comment that the
open spaces scheme i was
a little unhappy that it actually it
actually
came up only on the second of march day
before yesterday
i printed it all off yesterday gone
through it all
and that should have been before it was
a lot earlier for us to consider it
in real detail so i'm not very happy
about that
the other thing i want to ask is on this
drainage strategy
into into wooder road um
back in november um
matt collins wrote object into the
application
not acceptable in two major ways
um the impact of the drainage on the
public highway and the design of the
pedestrian routes through the site
and other issues he mentioned one that
he mentioned was
furthermore the same drawing shows
on-site drainage solutions
including attenuation crates now they're
still there on this
application such crates are not
acceptable
not acceptable within five meters of the
existing highway
or proposed adoptable highway areas
such drainage features must be moved
away from the highway
or provide provide a more robust
system of than crates details of any
attenuation drainage within five meters
of the highway are required to be
approved by our structural engineering
team
and will require a design and check
certificate and or approval in principle
to show that any loading on the highway
will not impact
on the integrity of the drainage
features or vice versa
and then and that was in only november
and then his last comments were
on the 16th of february further to
comments submitted on the 11th of
november
i can confirm that the new layout plans
the highway authority there is no
objection to application
yeah now i accept that there's to be a
legal agreement
between the county council highways and
the developer
on what's off-site the drainage
down wood erode in effect but they've
said
they want to note if this is approved to
that effect that we're not actually
giving planning permission
for this connection of surface water to
go into their system on muda road
but could not just clarify what happens
about these crates
that are still shown um and certainly
within five meters of the highway system
certainly chairman um my understanding
is that the conditions relating to
drainage
um with our flood risk management team
um
secure possibilities for changes to that
and the required technical approvals at
a later stage
so we so we we can make sure at that
point that they build
a system that that is adequate
right well again i'm unhappy i have been
at committee meetings in the past
that we don't get all the full
information here to make a decision on
because drainage of this site the
surface water drainage is very important
aspect of the site councilor locke
yeah um following on from cancer watson
i was also mined to approve the
application because i see that natural
england historic
england and our conservation officer
have got no objections
and county highways have now got no
objections
nor a southwest water nor the flood risk
management got any um objections to the
application
my one big concern was on page 57
was the lack of conditions i know that
many conditions as helen has already
said
are listed on the outline application
but i would like to have seen if the
matter is approved
um the management construction condition
added to this application would that be
possible please
it's already there ain't it thanks
councillor look i i thought that when i
looked
the conditions well the planned schedule
is referred to as
yeah i suppose the conditions that are
in that planned schedule of what
helen's alluding to but helen you can
answer for yourself yes
yes thank you thank you um thank you
chair
so um i'm assuming this is reference to
a construction management
plan um the the outline permission does
include a condition that requires
approval of a construction management
plan that has been provided and there is
a separate
discharge of condition application for
that that's not something we would
normally
we would then need to double up and
require as part of the reserve matters
application so
matters such as construction hours and
the need for a detailed construction
management plan has dealt with pursuant
to the outline
so we have received that and that is a
separate discharge of condition
application
which has been consulted with the
environmental protection officer
and just just drawing on council looks
point with that with the lack of
conditions i
i you know in writing the report myself
i did look and i was struggling to think
of more conditions to put on i think
it's worth worth sort of emphasizing
there are a lot of conditions on the
outline
many of them that of pre-commencement
and require
detailed technical um information
to the most noticeably in relation to
drainage
sort of ecological management plans and
adherence to the ecological impact
assessment
the noise assessment and the impact from
the shipyard
a lot of that detail and the need to
comply with certain
restrictions and certain um technical
specifications is all set out in the in
the outline
so in terms of this reserve masters and
what is before members
for consideration um there isn't a need
for a time condition because this sits
with the outline the outline sets out
the time
the information implementation time
scales any conditions on here can only
really relate to the reserve matters
that are before you for consideration
so the three that are recommended
um it's the plans proven the accordance
with the improved plans
securing the landscaping and and
materials
but i've also recommended the open space
scheme yeah
be secured so thank you for that so
um i will second council watson's
proposal that the application has
approved
thank you count sancho helen thank you
council a lot
right well unless anybody else wants to
contribute to the discussion on this
it's being recommended for approval by
councillor watson
seconded by councillor locke um
i'll just put this note in i think
probably from the committee but
certainly from
the ones we've spoken that we will be
looking in the future to resolve the
issue with
pit lane and pit hill which we obviously
can't do at this application stage but
that's a note for highways that you know
there are issues that do need addressing
there
and this committee will i'm pretty sure
be looking to make sure that they're
adequately addressed in the future
it's been approved it's been recommended
for approval then sandra could you take
the vote please
thank you chair uh council about him
four councillor brown laura
councillor christie against
cancer craigie poor
pencil leather poor pencil knock
or pencil mcgough
against cancer watson or
councillor wiseman oh
chair that's seven four and two against
thank you sandra right we move on then
agenda item eight is appeal decisions
there are no appeal decisions
nine is costs on appeals and there are
no costs on appeals
item 10 on page 60 is the agmb
decisions there there's three of them
there
and then we move on to item 11 which is
the planning decisions
on pages 61-68
i'll just go through the pages 61
62 63
councillor christie yeah thank you it's
just the one at the top of page 62 about
the trees
um i hope everyone got that email i sent
round
um pointed out that trees because they
live so long
most of them can be classed as diseased
it is the element of how disease they
are
and i i do hope that we you know we get
some really independent
studies of these because we're getting
quite a few uh which i'm glad to see we
never used to get these they are now
coming in but
um you know if i was a householder and i
hired a tree expert
i'd make sure i got one who was gonna
say what i wanted
um and i say this because we have lost a
couple of trees in biddeford in the last
couple of weeks which uh
you know uh anyway uh it's interesting
to see them but i hope we do look into
this
thank you yeah well i'll agree with you
there councillor christie
sean harrington sean you chair if i can
just come
come back at that point council christie
uh yes we do get uh
independent advice um with an
application such as this where
it's claimed that there is disease and
uh certainly with this particular
application
uh we did instruct an independent
consultant to have a look at that for us
and to confirm that was the case thank
you
right page 63 page 64.
page 65. i paid 68.
about 67.
um i wondered if you'd notice i've
missed that
67 council lock have you got something
on 67 seconds
i was just surprised that the golden bay
holidays are going to close three
challenges
and turn them into storage space when
everyone wrecking staycations are going
to be the end thing and they might be
losing some
um income from doing that it's only
happening
oh so that's i saw that i thought that's
unusual cancer christie
yeah i've only just noticed that
actually um halfway down p67
provision of aquaponic greenhouse what's
that
growing plants in water isn't it yeah
yeah no soil involved nothing like that
they hang up
i've seen it on gardner's question
gardener's world they
hang them up on in a greenhouse and it's
just fed on water
i thought that was hydroponics rather
than aquaponic it sounds like they're
breeding fish or something
well you might be right we would always
import the
soil from the eu yeah that would be
better
right that's the end of the planning
decisions
right chairman chairman it's
the solicitor not to everybody i don't
think you mentioned about page 66 as
well just for the sake of completeness
i'm it's 66 and 60.
yeah i think you you jump from 65 to 68
and then you went back to 66 sorry went
back to 67 and 68 but you didn't do 66.
i'm assuming nobody's got any comment
but i thought i better just double check
yeah all right thanks for spotting that
66 yeah perhaps i turned the two pages
over together
thanks for that okay right well
item 12 is the exclusion of public but
there's nothing else to discuss during
this formal
meeting this morning so i'll just say
thank you to those who've contributed
today
the members of the public those watching
on youtube the officers here
and all the committee of course thank
you for the third discussion we've had
and i'll close this formal